[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of these 2023 National
Championship things are heating up in
round nine but as we get ready uh to
bring you the action first we wanted to
welcome a very special guest on Studio
Alex kerford Alex welcome
aboard nice to be nice to have you
between Kate and I and Alex I got to
tell you obviously you wear a lot of
hats here in St Louis so if I can do do
uh some honors you're on the board of
directors of the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center you're really The Man
Behind the initiative for the corporate
chess League here in St Louis you're on
the US chess trust and you just recently
beat Rex singfield with your group of
all stars in the ultimate moves what is
it that you don't do It's Been a Good
Year it's been a good year for my career
in chess yes exactly well it's not a SLP
welcome aboard thank you very much thank
you for having me absolutely now tell me
a little bit about your work with the US
chess trust because Yuri showman was on
the show and he had been inducted into
the Hall of Fame and I know the US chess
trust does a lot for chess in the United
States so one of the one of the
highlights would be at the beginning of
this uh of the United States Chess
Championship being a part of the
ceremony to induct Yuri into the the
Hall of Fame it was it was a wonderful
ceremony it was a great time to play a
part in studying the accolades of
different people that are um selected as
candidates and then seeing them um be a
part of that ceremony was able to have
dinner with Yuri afterward and just to
hear his appreciation his gratitude of
being um in that is certainly a
highlight but I would say even bigger
than that uh would certainly be the
extension of the US chess trust in our
education programs and the Scholastic
support that we're doing to help schools
help organizations throughout the United
States um get involved and and be a part
of chess for decades exactly it has been
decades yeah no I I remember the US
chess drive way back in the day uh
really supporting also our Juniors and
our Allstars going to now all of these
youth championships around the world too
Kate so it's really really nice and uh
thank you for that and also the
corporate League uh yeah Alex you are
instrumental in founding in the
corporate chess League tell us how it
started and where the league is today
well like a lot of good ideas uh I was
having a drink with a friend of mine and
we were talking about the the the
massive kickball league that they have
here in St Louis and I just remembered
thinking about uh corporations do
softball leagues these these kickball
leagues now why don't we have a
corporate chess league and so I remember
calling the club I see Lauren there on
the screen and I talked with her about
that and just said hey hey here's this
this idea I don't know where we're going
to take it how it would work and
ultimately the St Louis chess club took
that idea and has ballooned it
into a staple here in St Louis now I
think we have 10 teams some 60 plus
players Washington University uh They
just added a team um we've had we have
lawyers we have financial advisers we
have all these different types of
careers that are now part of this this
corporate League Edward Jones yeah
you're the team captain right how did
your team do
Team Edward Jones has done pretty well
though wait a minute that didn't sound
like a first place wait a minute a
little bit of humble
Swagger we won a number of them so far
last year though team Enterprise was the
big winner and um but it's always been
competitive a lot of great players come
out and it's about the networking these
cross industry ideas that are shared
that a lot of the the aspects of Chess
that translate over into your your
industry and so that's what we've been
seeing with the corporate chess leagues
development I remember being present at
some of these events and it's really
nice networking even where people talk
about Chess but also talk about their
stuff and just enjoy competing against
each other absolutely it's been a lot of
fun Christian you're going to put our
guest on the hot seat yeah okay go for
it I have to what was your question we
have this incredible race in the ladies
section yeah you have beame Karissa and
then you have this big Clash that we're
watching right now Fabby with the black
pie is defending against Hans you have
been following the Championships who are
your
favorites win on the ladies on the
ladies I will start with my with my
friend my partner in crime going back
when her and I played against uh varujan
and Rex in a in a in a duel Karissa Yip
will come back and win the female uh us
CH Championship that's that's a good
start I mean you're doing quite well so
far
right decent chances okay so on the on
the open section open section with Bobby
one point lead but next three round
three rounds this our next world
champion and oh US champion and US
champion will be Fabiano Carana also
predicting you heard it the world CH you
heard it here first yeah that's that's a
good prediction I like it wow now I said
fa me too that's our I did it before the
event started so like you got to give me
a little bit more credit on this one I
said h i mean I'm doing quite well
you're in the mix I said first right
before you even I'm not sure we're going
to have to go to the tape check the
check the tape on Now One Alex once
again thank you again for everything
that you've done and I also lastly I
know you're also involved with the quesa
club as well here uh we have our quesa
dinners and uh the big chest set of
outside the World Chess Hall of Fame
we've got our names on the squares as we
uh contribute each and every year to the
quesa club and that's a really nice one
too absolutely the number of things that
the St Louis chess club and World Chess
Hall of Fame have done in the St Louis
area in our community um over the past
uh 10 or longer than that now over 10
years has been absolutely amazing so my
wife and I have been involved with the
kaissa club um I believe about seven
years now and it's been been great to
get to see some of the um behind the
scene things that get to happen and
being engaged in so many ways so really
appreciate the opportunity and all that
the club is doing conversely thank you
so much Alex for everything you thank so
much and I have actually one last
question I know your children also play
chess they've attended summer chess
games what are your plans for for them
and their chess career I I just try and
right now hope that they have a lot of
fun I hope that they are enjoying it and
seeing the curriculum that they're doing
at school complemented by the curriculum
that they're getting through chess
helping with concentration with reading
those would be some of the big things I
hope that they're able to get from chess
right now and uh and that they can't
beat dad
yet very important very important don't
get too far ahead of yourselves
youngsters okay keep dad in the mix uh
once again